what are you most excited for for the
direct I have to say Indie right because
Indie it it for a couple of reasons
right go Indie isn't a property that's
big right now right they tried to sort
of bring him back was it two years ago
now that last movie didn't do super well
I haven't seen it yet but I heard that
for Indie fans it was fine it's just it
was whatever whatever the expectation
for Indie now is whatever it's the
general consensus wasn't great but for
Indie fans I think a lot of people liked
it especially compared to you that last
one um they trashed on it too which is
kind of czy yeah exactly they trashed on
it as well so it's like I want to see
what they do with it because it's going
to be a telling thing uh I agree with
addict that I you know this back and
forth between first and third person
machine games has never done third
person so I'd be excited to see that
because again we talk about the hasht
just one and getting that third person
action game um